[Music]
hi everybody i'm dave staston alongside
jeff worthing and welcome to the annual
east west bowl
as we get ready to watch some of the
best college players in the nation
showcase their skills in a classic
showdown between
east and west and there really are some
characters
on this year's squads aren't there jeff
that's right dave it does seem like the
most flamboyant personalities came to
the forefront and they
are here let's meet the players from the
east
[Music]
to marcus williams university of georgia
t.j jackson wayne state university
tavares smith king
merrimack college todd royal smoochie
wallace
university miami the squarius green
junior
university of notre dame ibrahimo
zeus university of tennessee at
chattanooga
marius tax theratrix michigan state
university
the isaiah t billings club coastal
carolina university
the jasper probing crux iii south
carolina state
university leo's maxwell jillian's
east carolina university javaris jamar
javaris and lamar
university of middle tennessee the des
moines shower handle
university of southern mississippi
jingle mckringleberry
penn state university la carpetron
duke marriott florida atlantic
university
the dinklage morgoon university of south
florida
x miss jackson flax and waxing
california university of pennsylvania
[Music]
we're going to be looking for big plays
all game long from tyrol
smoochie wallace and let's not forget
the tight ends
ibrahim moyesus and hingle
mckringleberry they've both had amazing
seasons that's right jeff
now let's meet the players from the west
vegetarian jefferth texas a
m the cluster how dunkin should
university of wisconsin
swerve within l gooding's flat
saskatchewan university
cuatro cuatro san jose state university
awesome taz buckshack
stanford university these are 12 washing
beard
jones college shakira quan tjif carter
university of northern arizona x wayne
at aliciousness missouri western state
university sequester grundlepleth md
adam state scores philosoraptor malloys
south dakota state university tj aj
rj backslashes fourth the fifth i'll be
in college
san diego state university donkey teeth
boise state university tork
lewis nevada state
penitentiary the player formerly known
as mouse cop university of missouri
colombia dan smith byu
[Music]
i'm dave sassen alongside jeff worthing
and welcome to the 2013 east west pole
where we're going to be watching some of
the best college athletes in the nation
try to put last year's spectacle to
shame that's right dave it
won't be easy but this year's seniors
certainly
will be trying to give last year's stars
a run for their money
let's check out the team starting with
the players from the east
[Music]
cos nestor smith righteous university
ellipses quarter university of alabama
now aquila's still wide lsu
bismol funyuns florida state university
de captain like mango georgia tech
university
margaret schedule university of
louisville
chris not business university of
tennessee
the parish poop shed ole miss
quackadilly blip auburn university
ghoulius boozler the you
miss katine triskin university of
michigan
fall trail cloggins university of
arkansas
splaron washington
c2 cartoons plural
virginia tech jammy jimmy jammy
v ohio state university
fudge
some of the big stories this year the
meteoric rise
of de pez poopsie and let's not forget
about heisman winner
jimmy jamie jamie and remember you can't
talk about 2013 without bringing up
fudge
everybody's talking about fudge at 350
pounds this running back is
almost unstoppable the whole year you're
right i could talk about fudge all day
but first let's meet the players from
the west
equine ducklings indiana university
purdue university indianapolis
dar historius la mistorious utah state
university iwakonias
junior steam oklahoma state university
exquisite team buble schwenzlone
university of nebraska
hookah naka hakanaka hikaluka hookah
akafaka
university of hawaii king prince
chambermaid
baylor university the jennifer jedana
state
university of colorado la da da da da da
da
da la da da la da la da university of
arizona
harvard university
devry universities
rv navy surplus store
wing digs online classes
first name last name college university
god home school
squeeze santa monica college
benedict cumberbatch oxford university
a.a ron belake morehouse college
[Music]
hey your dinkle edge yeah la carpetron
check out leo's
i wonder what he's dreaming about he is
probably
dreaming about what we is gonna do to
the team from the west
i wonder
[Music]
tavarious miss t king for short i'm a
bad mamma gemma and an awful sport
smoochie wallace you could call me ty
royale wrapping up rushers like aluminum
foils the queen goldberry i'm very scary
if i got the ball you best be worried
the carpetron duke marion i love the
ball so much i want to marry
[Music]
we are the best we are the best
[Music]
i'm ibrahim and my rhymes are clean like
my name was dr seuss
probably the third they call me the
probe i can intercept balls with my elo
shower handle that's my name power
candle
sounds the same with jack mary the
swearing javaris and le mans flag the
wax and play saxon demarcus plays guitar
[Music]
we are the best
it must have been all a dream
or was it
[Music]
oh it's on
[Music]
what's up y'all it's jefferson
[Music]
i'll use my force to give the east
distress air good and splatters where
it's at
running through defenders and path is my
stats y'all know me
i'm washing beard catch so many balls
it's a little weird the voices running
through my head
[Music]
the player dj aj formerly known
[Music]
daniel other kickers in the league don't
hold a candle cheer leaders up on the
chocolate crotch with goddamn baby
cocker spaniel byu why you be
back as the [ __ ] wanna get with me got
swisher sweets and thoughts he's rolling
and numb summer team could touch these
hitting field goals blunted
been drunk when i punished been like a
hundred times that i already done it
oh see these haters thought i was
playing staying away from my faces with
all the books they're saying but just
remember people
talking when you're tossing those
gauntlets from dan smith and the west is
getting rowdy like monsters
you